good morning John I personally live for
the hugs like I live for VidCon I live
for those me green you are defining the
culture that people will talk about for
decades to comes about the value of an
audience and about the value of honesty
those who are in it today are the ones
who are going to understand it the best
tomorrow and be a part of it as it
evolve that's what I'm investing in I
want to be a part of this as it grows
it's nonstop happiness I love VidCon
lots of not sleeping out of 12 million
subs 12,000 people is what got us to
where we were shattering records just
having the ability and the freedom to
create whatever you want
come on so how could I let you go
Oh anyone can
keeper keeper keeper keeper with you
yeah
keep up keep up keep up keep up keep
away
justkeep
VidCon 2015 is officially a thing that
is going to be a thing we started VidCon
back in 2010 because online video was
amazing and we wanted there to be a time
and a place where it could exist in the
real world for a weekend now headed into
its sixth year it has gotten to be quite
a big thing it's a convention in a
conference in a celebration and a
discussion and I'm gonna spend the rest
of this video talking about it last year
VidCon had 20,000 people at it and this
is gonna be the first year where VidCon
doesn't grow we're gonna cut off ticket
basically the same size as last year we
are changing some things so let's talk
about that first we're still doing the
photo signing meet-and-greet thing at
VidCon but we're basically Disney fast
passing it everyone who registers for a
community track ticket will in early
spring get a message asking them to rank
the people that they would like to meet
in order that they would like to meet
the based on that ranking the system
will assign tickets to people if you get
a ticket your badge becomes your pass
there's a barcode on it that will let
you into the line and you just have to
show up like a half an hour before the
signing starts because you're guaranteed
to be in the line goal is that everyone
will arrive at VidCon knowing what to
expect second the whole Convention
Center same number of people twice as
much space we're gonna have five main
floor stages that everyone at the
conference will have access to these
stages will have things like panels on
the culture of online video and the
internet including discussions of race
and gender host performances and
interviews in audience Q&A and live
shows and dance parties and concerts and
contests and having all this space on
the ground floor has allowed us to
number three create a new track a
creator track for people who aren't just
fans but who are interested in the
process and craft and business of
creating online video there'll be panels
workshops discussions allowed
specifically for creator pass holders
and a creator specific keynote session
it's slightly more expensive and because
of limited capacity in the signing hall
that doesn't have access to any of the
signings or photos but it includes all
the rest of the downstairs content did
come 2015 is going to be I think
fantastic we've got a great team put
together and we're already designing a
bunch of amazing content that I'm really
excited about other the vast majority of
people who want to go to VidCon can't go
to VidCon just because of you know size
of the planet so of course I have to end
this video by just apologizing to all of
you who can't call the good news is the
real culture of online video it happens
right here and you have access to that I
assume because of how you were listening
to my words John for the last time in a
while at least I'll see you tomorrow
just a final Pizza mess on screen about
how great this has been to do it this
way for a couple of weeks I
keep it up but I'm so glad we did it
John I know it was even harder for you
being on the set and everything but
thanks for doing it it's been so cool
thanks to everyone for being here for
Pete Smith it's fun so good
it felt good